The Nightmare Before Christmas is a beloved
classic, one of the most singularly quirky
and amazing animated films, holiday movies,
and musicals of all time, all rolled into
one.
Coming from the mind of producer Tim Burton
and bearing his distinct visual stamp, the
stop-motion animated feature has become a
staple of the holidays since its 1993 release.
One of the true joys of The Nightmare Before
Christmas is how amazingly true it is to the
tone and spirit of both Halloween and Christmas,
and it's easy to see why the film has become
a yearly tradition for so many.
But considering its financial and critical
success and its impact on the world of pop
culture, what's not so easy to puzzle out
is why we never got a sequel to the classic
film.
Why did we never get The Nightmare Before
Christmas 2?
"Terrible news, folks!
The worst tragedy of our times!"
It's not like the idea hasn't been kicked
around.
In particular, the film's director Henry Selick
- who would go on to work on two additional
stop-motion features, 2006's James and the
Giant Peach and 2009's Coraline - has gone
on record stating that while he could be enticed
to return to Halloween Town.
But the notion was complicated by Disney.
It seems that the House of Mouse was only
interested in a sequel to the classic on one
specific condition - one that Selick wasn't
too keen on.
In a 2009 interview, Selick revealed that
discussions about a sequel had in fact taken
place, saying,
"A few years back, Disney spoke to me and
the sad thing was at the time, they said,
'If we do a sequel, it will have to be CG.'
I was really disappointed.
I asked why, and they didn't think stop-motion
was a viable way to make movies [...] I don't
think Tim would allow a CG sequel.
There's been a few stories proposed and a
few discussions, but that's really Tim's decision."
In sharing this, Selick hit upon one major
roadblock to any sequel to The Nightmare Before
Christmas: Burton, who first conceived the
story and characters in a poem he wrote as
a young man in the early '80s.
In a 2006 interview with MTV News, the filmmaker
indicated that he may not be terribly open
to the idea of any sequel, CG or otherwise.
He told MTV,
"I was always very protective of [the movie],
not to do sequels or things of that kind.
You know, 'Jack visits Thanksgiving world'
or other kinds of things, just because I felt
the movie had a purity to it and the people
that like it.
Because it's not a mass-market kind of thing,
it was important to kind of keep that purity
of it."
That's certainly understandable, but even
if some persistent executive had been able
to convince Burton to make The Nightmare Before
Christmas 2 any way he wanted, there were
many years during which it just wouldn't have
been possible - because the filmmaker wasn't
speaking to his star, Danny Elfman, who provided
Jack's singing voice.
In case you're not familiar with Elfman, you
should know that you are, in fact, familiar
with Elfman.
The former front man for new wave pioneers
Oingo Boingo, Elfman has composed so much
music for film and television - including
the iconic Simpsons theme - that it'd be virtually
impossible to have never heard any of his
work.
Elfman has worked with Burton on no fewer
than 16 films, and during the course of their
long professional relationship, the two famously
eccentric personalities didn't always play
nice together.
In a 2015 interview, Elfman revealed that
the pair had a big blow up right after work
on The Nightmare Before Christmas was completed
- one which would have kept the musical voice
of Jack from participating in any sequel for
some time.
Elfman recalled,
"It was in the middle of a very intense period
[...] and I think things came to a boil.
It's inevitable that in over a quarter of
a century, two personalities like us - and
I can't pretend that I'm not volatile and
was more so then - there's gotta be some kind
of explosion."
The pair resolved their differences several
years later, but they did lose a lot of time
during which The Nightmare Before Christmas
was fresh in the minds of the movie-going
public.
To be sure, the original film would be a tough
act to follow, even assuming that Burton,
Elfman, and Selick could be coaxed back on
board.
You may have heard, however, that the House
of Mouse has recently been diving into its
archives in pursuit of box office gold - meaning
that if we ever do get more Nightmare Before
Christmas, it may not necessarily be in the
form of a sequel.
Disney's recent live-action remakes of its
classic animated properties have, for the
most part, done bonkers box office.
Interestingly, the sole exception is 2019's
Dumbo, a comparative flop that just happened
to have been directed by Tim Burton - not
that this would keep Disney from eyeing The
Nightmare Before Christmas for the live-action
treatment.
In fact, it's recently been rumored that the
studio is considering doing just that - and
these rumors surfaced early in 2019, before
Aladdin and The Lion King each scored over
a billion dollars at the worldwide box office.
With Mulan, The Little Mermaid, and more looking
to continue the trend, it stands to reason
that the Mouse House might be taking a hard
look at their stop-motion holiday classic
for possible live-action adaptation.
Of course, it should be stressed that these
are merely rumors and are in no way confirmed
- but at this point, a live-action redo seems
a lot more likely than a stop-motion sequel.
Honestly, we'll take either one - just for
the chance to see Jack the Pumpkin King back
up on the big screen one more time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.